Nehmer mich gestellt,
dass ich den auch einen ausschalten kann.
Wir werden überprüfen,
wir werden uns
meinen Router auslesen,
wir werden vom Raspberry
sowas wie,
versuchen wir zumindest,
sowas wie RAM-Belegung und
Disk-Usage und sowas auszulesen
und dann
einmal was zu bauen, wo einfach drinnen steht
alles gut oder host up, host down
und wir werden so ein bisschen
Grafenauswertung machen
was über meinen Router drüber geht
und wie schnell zum Beispiel
die Festplatte von meinem Raspberry
die SD-Karte von meinem Raspberry vollläuft,
dass das Ding nicht wieder abkackt, weil
ich hab das so vor, dass mir das Ding
dann halt Bescheid sagt, hey
Raspberry, guck mal, System, über 90%
Festplattenplatz und
es kackt demnächst ab
und ich will nix großartig aufgeblähtes
haben, ich will kein Zabbix oder ich will kein
Nagios oder irgendwas, ich will was
ganz einfaches, simples
haben, was ich auch
nach einem Jahr noch kapiere
soweit dazu, ne
Warst du auf der
Artikel 13 Demo?
Ich war nicht auf der Hauptdemo
ich war an der Hauptwache
vor ein paar Tagen davor war das
das war so zwei Wochen
davor, abends
auf der Hauptdemo war ich nicht
ihr wisst ja, ich hab's nicht so sehr mit
Kontakt mit echten Leuten
mit echten Leuten
vor allem nicht, wenn das ganz viele
Leute sind, die ich erstens nicht kenne und zweitens
die so viel auf engem Raum sind
das ist nicht meins, das wisst ihr ja vielleicht schon
also die, die öfters
reingucken, wissen das
die Katze sitzt jetzt auf dem
Schrank und putzt sich
so geht das
wir sind alle Bots, ja genau
dieses Thema, eigentlich wollte ich
dazu ja, ich wollte dazu eigentlich gar nichts sagen
eigentlich wollte ich dazu dieser ganze
Artikel 13 Geschichte gar nichts sagen
aber wenn ich mir angucke
wie dreist das teilweise
ignoriert wird
was die Leute, was Leute wollen
beziehungsweise
das abgetan wird mit den bescheuertsten Gründen
zuerst wurde ja erzählt so nach dem Motto
ähm
genau, das erste, das erste was erzählt hat
da war der Voss ganz vorne mit dabei wieder
der hat ja auch, der hat jetzt auch den Ruf weg
das ist egal
der kann höchstens noch irgendwann mal zu Axel Springer in Aufsichtsrat gehen
oder sowas in der Richtung, aber ansonsten
sonst will den Typ keiner mehr sehen, als erstes haben sie irgendwie erzählt
wie es gibt Leute, die dagegen sind
das kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, dass es Leute gibt, die gegen Artikel 13 sind
das kann, das kann nicht sein
ich habe jetzt da keinen Widerspruch gehört
da haben die Leute rumgeschrien so nach dem Motto
Alter, hier Widerspruch
das ist ja der Moment, Moment, Moment
das kann ja auch nicht sein, weil
das kam ja alles von englischen
von US-E-Mail-Adressen
weil es Google Mail ist und das, nein das geht auch nicht
das kann nicht sein und das ist ja
das ist ja auch, ja und dann
Hallo Leute, Protest, wir wollen, wir wollen den Scheiß nicht
ne, also das ist mit Sicherheit eingekauft
das kann nicht sein, also das ist ja auch nicht so, das kann nicht sein
das ist nicht möglich, ja zwischendrin waren wir auch noch Bots
ja, das habe ich ganz vergessen
ähm
und ich frage mich halt
wie dreist man sein kann, dass man so
extrem an
dem vorbei
entscheidet, beziehungsweise
ähm
geistig in komplett anderen Sphären
irgendwie schwebt, wie das, was die
Leute vor einer Woche davor
noch erzählt haben, ich meine klar
es muss nicht unbedingt so sein, dass nur
weil jemand der Lauteste ist, unbedingt auch
wenige ist, der Recht hat, allerdings
in dem Fall, äh, ich habe
keinerlei Protest dafür
gesehen, ehrlich gesagt, sondern nur dagegen
und eigentlich auch so ziemlich jeden, den du fragst
der ist
entweder neutral oder
dagegen, so wirklich glühende
Verfechter davon sehe ich jetzt
relativ wenig
und ich bin eh der Ansicht
die haben einen großen Fehler begangen
mit dieser Artikel 13 Geschichte
und das hat mit Artikel 13 überhaupt
nichts zu tun
und zwar, die haben Millionen junger
Leute aufgeweckt
die sich jetzt auf einmal dafür interessieren
das sind Millionen Leute, die
früher gesagt haben, die noch vor wenigen Monaten
gesagt haben, scheiß drauf
ähm, interessiert mich alles
nicht und haben links und rechts
alle machen lassen, wie sie wollten
und jetzt haben sie
quasi Millionen junger Bots aufgeweckt
die sich auf einmal dafür interessieren
mal gucken, wie lange das anhält
ähm, ich nehme die
meisten Sachen ja normalerweise nicht so ernstlich
ja, also ich gehe bei vielen Sachen
wo erzählt wird so nach dem Motto
oh, das sind bahnbrechende Erkenntnisse
oh, das wird einschneidende Auswirkungen haben
und hier und bla und sonst was
ähm, gehe ich erstmal davon aus, dass das eigentlich
äh, nichts viel
nicht viel machen wird, aber bei dieser
Geschichte, ich will nicht sagen
der Anfang vom Ende, das ist viel zu überzogen
aber ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass diese Sache jetzt
ähm, dazu
führen könnte
dass es in ein paar Jahren
komplett anders aussieht, wie das auf
europäischer Ebene läuft
von der Zusammensetzung her
oder auch vom
ja, vom gesamten Apparat her, weil ich meine
du kannst nicht auf einmal Millionen junger Leute
das eher, guck mal, die Leute
die da jetzt dabei waren, die dürfen zum ersten Mal
wählen gehen und vor allem hat sie es bisher nicht
interessiert und das erste
die hat es bisher nicht interessiert und im Hinterkopf
hatten sie immer den Gedanken so nach dem Motto
okay, die werden das schon ordentlich machen
das ist ja auch das, womit man mit, sagen wir mal
normalem, ähm,
Weltbild hier, wenn man hier aufgewachsen ist
so rangeht, so nach dem Motto, okay
ähm, ich gehe erstmal standardmäßig
davon aus, dass, ähm
die Leute, die, ich sag mal, die Profis
in dem Gebiet, ja, dass die Leute sich damit richtig
beschäftigen und das ordentlich machen
das ist das erste, wovon man eigentlich
so im Hinterkopf ausgeht, solange man noch nichts anderes
mitgekriegt hat und jetzt ist das
Problem, dass sie Millionen
junger Leute aufgeweckt haben und das erste
womit sie in Kontakt kommen ist, dass
sie angeschissen werden, dass sie belogen werden
beschissen werden, ähm, ihnen der
größte Mist erzählt wird, dass sie nicht ernst
genommen werden, dass versucht wird, alles
abzutun, wofür sie sich
eingesetzt haben, sprich das erste, womit die Leute
in Kontakt gekommen sind, ist, es sackt
und ihr wisst, wie
schwerwiegend so der erste Eindruck ist
oder wie schwer es ist, den ersten Eindruck
wieder, ähm, wegzukriegen
das heißt, die haben jetzt nicht nur
Millionen Leute aufgeweckt, die haben jetzt Millionen
Leute den Ersteindruck verpasst
sie sind die größten Spasten ever
und, ähm,
es wird alles getan, um nicht
zu
quasi
das zu machen, was die jungen Leute sich wünschen
und
das könnte ich mir vorstellen
dass das dazu führen wird, dass das in ein paar
Jahren alles anders aussehen wird
und wovon ich auch ausgehe
ist, dass es weiter
Zuspruch geben wird, für
extrem, aber für
ähm, zumindest nicht
den etablierten Parteien, sondern ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass zum Beispiel die AfD jede Menge neue
Wähler bekommen wird, so wie das zum Beispiel, die hat gerade
auch einer im Chat geschrieben, weil es
ist einfach so, die müssen, also ich
bin der Ansicht nach, man muss sich langsam nicht mehr wundern
man kann sich doch nicht wundern
huch, wo rennen denn die ganzen Leute hin
huch, warum mag uns denn keiner, huch, warum wählt uns denn mehr
keiner, wenn man quasi
konsistent
die letzten Jahre über hinweg, sich
nicht mit den Sachen auseinandersetzt
die die Leute interessieren
also
da muss man sich doch nicht wundern
ja, und man darf sich
nicht vormachen, dass das jetzt irgendjemand vielleicht
irgendwie besser wüsste, ja, es
ist vollkommen egal, ob es jetzt die Linken sind, die AfD
die Grünen, wer auch immer, die wissen das auch nicht
besser, die Sache ist bloß die, dass
ähm, dass
zumindest die Leute, glaube ich, zumindest den Eindruck
haben, dass sich die etablierten Parteien
noch nicht mal mehr dafür interessieren
oder noch nicht mal mehr überhaupt zuhören wollen
was die Leute denn wirklich, äh, bewegt
ja, und wenn du die Auswahl hast
zwischen einem, der dir zuhört
und dann vielleicht, ähm, nichts macht
oder einen, der von Anfang an sagt
leck mich am Arsch, es interessiert mich überhaupt nicht, was du sagst
dann entscheidest du dich natürlich für den
was man zumindest so tut, als würde dir zuhören
ja, das ist, äh
äh
wie man, wie man geistig
so abgehoben sein kann im Kopf, ja
und, äh, dass
das auch, das auch noch verteidigt
und im Nachhinein dann sagt, ja
im Nachhinein dann sagt, so nach dem Motto
ja, also
ich hab jetzt dafür gestimmt
aber eigentlich
eigentlich finde ich's doch kack, aber ich hab
dafür gestimmt, ja, ich mein, was musst du denn für
ein Spaß sein, was musst du denn
für der übelste Lappen sein, ich mein, wenn du davon
überzeugt bist, ich mein, dafür sitzt du doch
da letztendlich, wenn du davon überzeugt
bist, dass es Mist ist
ne, entweder nimmst du ein bisschen Stress auf
dich und sagst, okay, ich entscheide mich jetzt gegen
das, was vielleicht mein Chef will, aber
ich bin ja hier letztendlich nicht, weil ich
meinen Chef, äh, zufriedenstellen soll
sondern vielleicht, weil ich
die Leute vertreten will, die mich gewählt haben
dann musst du dich hinstellen und sagen, hä, ich bin
dagegen, das hat, was einer, einer von
der CDU, CSU gemacht hat, einer hat dagegen
gestimmt, ähm,
oder, aber du machst einfach mit
ohne, ohne Sinn und Verstand
Habt ihr zufällig, dass
diese, den Ausschnitt
mit Dehner bei dieser einen Talkshow
gesehen? Also ich mein,
jetzt nicht den Teppichhändler, sondern
den Minecraft-Dehner, der gar
kennt, der, ne, ich sag nicht mehr der Minecraft-Dehner, das ist ja
der, der Rennfahrer-Dehner ist es jetzt ja mittlerweile
soweit ich das mitkrieg
muss grad mal Vorschau gucken, hab ich, hab ich
Low-Latency-Stream an? Ja, müsste
ich eigentlich haben
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Mit
Dehner bei einer Talkshow?
Ja
Das fand ich echt gut, ähm,
das, also der hat das wirklich gut gemacht
Es ist nicht einfach, ja
sich da hinzustellen, vor allem
es ist, es ist
ein Unterschied
ob du, ob man Erfahrung hat
in sowas oder nicht. Ich geh mal davon
aus, er hat schon ein bisschen Erfahrung in dem
Gebiet, aber ich mein, die Typen, die da gesessen
haben, haben jahrelang Erfahrung
quasi eben vor der Kamera sitzen und
öffentlich labern. Und dafür
hat sich gut gemacht. Es geht bei solchen Talkshows
nicht darum, ähm, ob du, ob du recht hast oder
nicht recht hast oder so. Es geht halt darum, das
irgendwie gut zu verkaufen. Und die Leute, die da
gesessen haben, hatten in der Regel eigentlich
jahrelang Übung, Sachen gut zu verkaufen, egal wie
groß das Schwachsinn ist. Und, äh, letztendlich, ähm,
konnte Dehner da schon ordentlich punkten, ja.
Ich glaub, die Leute haben das immer noch nicht so
ganz gecheckt. Vor allem auch die Sache, die er
erzählt hat, dass es ja jetzt schon so ist und
das ist auch eine Sache, die ich nicht verstehe,
dass das, dass da drüber nicht diskutiert wird.
Zum Beispiel, es ist ja jetzt schon so, dass wenn
ich in meinem YouTube-Video irgendwie, äh, was weiß
ich, um so übertrieben zu sagen, äh, mein Nachbar
spielt im Hof den Epic Sucks Guy und ich nehm grad
ein Video in meinem Garten auf, dann, ne, hab ich
schon Content-ID-Probleme. Und das ist ja jetzt
schon eigentlich viel zu übertrieben. Das ist ja
der, das kommt ja auch noch dabei. Es ist jetzt
schon teilweise viel zu krass. Aber jetzt, jetzt kommt,
ja, aber das ist egal. Die tun jetzt dann quasi so,
als ist das jetzt erst so. Dabei ist das schon die
ganze Zeit so. Sind alle ins Wort gefalle? Ja, gut.
Das, das ist, das, das, äh, ist irgendwie so Sitte
bei denen. Ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum.
Ähm, das, das, das führt weder dazu, dass man die
Leute besser von seiner Sache noch von einer anderen
Sache überzeugen kann. Ähm, ja. Gut. Ähm, jetzt
aber, sind wir ein bisschen abgeschweift von der
ganzen Sache, ja.
Der ohne Kohl. Nice. Ja. Ähm, ich wollte jetzt mal
gucken, hab ich irgendwas, ähm, äh, Chat überlesen.
Was ist eigentlich aus, äh, aus deinem Do Yourself
nass geworden? Ähm, ich hab, ich hab das gebaut, aber
das steht immer noch rum. Weil, das kann ich auch
gleich, kann ich, kann ich, kann ich was zu sagen. Ich
will nämlich noch, ich würde mir gerne sowas hier
kaufen. Das würde ich mir gerne kaufen. Das Problem
ist, das gibt's gerade nicht.
Das ist die gleiche Plattform, wie wir gerade haben,
nur, dass die einen vierfach PCI Express hat und, ähm,
einen Vierkern, Vierkern-CPU. Und die aktuellen Boards,
die es für mein Nass gab, hatten entweder, ähm, eine
ordentliche PCI Express-Anbindung und nur zwei
Kerne oder aber vier Kerne und kein ordentliches PCI
Express. Und das Board ist eigentlich ziemlich gut. Es
ist, es kostet 40 Euro mehr als die anderen. Ähm, das
ist ziemlich gut. Du hast vierfach PCI Express, zweimal
Computer, ähm, die man, die, die, die, die man erweitern
kann. Ähm, und vier, viermal PCI Express, also kannst du
mit einem, mit einem Multiplier, äh, mit einem Port-Multiplier
erweitern auf, ich glaub, bis zu zehn. Ähm, und das ist
eigentlich eine bessere Plattform. Aber ich, das ist, es
läuft immer noch, ja. Ich hab mir übrigens bei AliExpress
ein paar Starter-Port-Multiplier gekauft, die sind bis
heute nicht angekommen. Hast du eigentlich wieder Kabel-Internet bekommen?
Im Juni endlich VDSL 100. Ja, ich bin über Unity-Media grad drin, aber das ist noch die
alte Unity-Media-Leitung. Ähm, ich kann, ich, ich bin, die Telekom bin ich erst ab
August los. Telekom bin ich erst ab August los. Aber ich hab's, ich hab's so gemacht,
wie wir im Stream geplant haben. Ähm, mein, mein VoIP-Anschluss geht zu denen hier. Also
sprich, das Festnetz, das geht zu denen hier. Das da. Drei Euro im Monat. Telefoniere eh
nicht. Geht einfach nur darum, dass man eine Festnetz-Summe hat. Hier geht meine VoIP-Nummer
von der Telekom hin. Und, ähm, Internet geht, Unity-Media. Internet geht komplett zu Unity-Media.
Und die haben ja auch schon zugesichert, dass ich meinen, äh, vollwertigen IPv4 oder alternativ
sogar einen vollwertigen Dual-Stack-Anschluss behalten kann. Und wenn man das schriftlich
hat, ist schon mal ganz gut. Dann, dann, wenn die das nicht machen, dann werde ich auf Twitter
wieder monatelang durch den Dreck zerfallen.
So, und zumindest als Paket hab ich jetzt, ähm, das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Ich hab
weder das noch das da. Ja, genau. Ich hab das hier mit Upload, mit Mega-Upload, mit,
ähm, Power-Upload oder wie der, wie der Krempel heißt. Äh, wo kommt man das überhaupt einstellen
mit Power-Upload jetzt? Ich will mal zeigen, was das kostet. Hier, Details, was ist das?
Wahrscheinlich. Mit Power-Upload, genau. Dann, warte mal, wir tun mal so, als wollen
wir es bestellen, äh, in den Warenkorb. Also, das hier ist das wichtige 50 Euro monatlich
und das stimmt, das stimmt ja auch nicht. Das ist ja auch nur schön gerechnet, ne?
Mit den 50 Euro monatlich. Das sind 50 Euro monatlich für den, für den Anschluss. Dann
kommen, hallo? Okay, was, was auch immer. Dann kommen nochmal irgendwie 2 Euro oder
so dabei für den Power-Upload.
Ist die Unity-Media-Seite, spack gerade übelst rum. Ähm, für den Power-Upload. Ähm, dann
kommen noch, ich glaub, 20 Euro dabei für den Kabelanschluss. Also, sprich, das kostet
irgendwie 75 Euro oder sowas im Monat. Plus nochmal, plus nochmal die Gebühr für, für
VoIP bei EasyBell. Also, ich bezahl irgendwie 77 Euro oder sowas im Monat und hab dafür
halt, äh, 100 Down, 40 Up und bin die Telekom los.
Und einen ordentlichen Anschluss.
Muss mal kurz. Äh, schon Battlefield 5 Firestorm gespielt? Nee.
Honker Shake.
Dual Stack, Dual Stack Light, beste. Ja, so eine Kacke, äh.
Adblock muss aus, ich hab überhaupt keinen Adblock an.
Wieso 50 Euro?
Äh, ab dem, weil es ab dem, ich, ich rechne das immer ab dem, was es dann eigentlich kostet, ne?
Ich meine, das stimmt ja nicht. Das ist ja richtig. Eigentlich bezahlt man weniger und ich bezahle jetzt auch nicht,
weil ich, wie gesagt, ich hab ja, ich hab ja geschrieben,
ich will kündigen. Ähm, ich bezahle auch das erste Jahr nicht die, äh, 50 Euro.
Ähm, aber es sind ja eigentlich mehr. Der Kabelanschluss kommt eh noch oben drauf und sowas.
So. Ähm, hab ich jetzt noch irgendwas vergessen? Bevor wir anfangen.
Also, ne? Ich, ich hab ja schon erzählt, was ich machen will. Ich will meinen, ich könnte mal den Raspberry einschalten.
Fällt mir grad ein. Ich schalte mal, ich schalte mal den Raspberry ein.
Das wird grad.
Ich schalte mal schon den...
So.
Dass der schon mal starten kann.
Hab mittlerweile eingesehen, dass Battle Royale nichts für mich ist.
Das hab ich schon ziemlich schnell eingesehen.
Oder beziehungsweise, das hab ich schon relativ schnell gemerkt, dass Battle Royale ist.
Das ist nicht mein Spielmodus.
Was ich interessant finde ist, hab ich eigentlich schon ein Bild von meiner neuen Katz gezeigt?
Ähm.
Ich, ich find ja auch, dass der Apex-Hype wieder, wieder...
...weg ist.
Na, der Apex-Hype hat sich schon erledigt.
Ist Hanau asozial?
Ähm.
Also, Hanau in der Innenstadt? Ja.
Dicke Katze, guck mal.
Da isser.
Wobei, die, die, das Bild, ne? Die sieht auf dem Bild viel, viel dicker aus, als sie letztendlich ist.
Da, da sieht sie nicht so dick aus. Hier sieht sie auch nicht so dick aus.
Ja.
Chico.
Also, sie heißt Chico, weil der, die ehemalige Besitzerin, glaube ich, hat sich...
...äh, ich weiß nicht.
Das ist nicht Katzor V2, das ist wenn schon Katzor, äh, äh, V3.
Das hier ist die Originale.
Das ist die Originale gewesen.
Das hier.
Meine erste Katz.
Das hier ist die zweite Katz.
Und, äh, Chico ist die dritte Katz.
Ja, ich hatte ein bisschen Pech mit meinen Katzen, oder die Katzen mit mir, weil...
...eigentlich ging's denen bei mir immer gut.
Und ich glaub denen hat's auch gefallen, aber irgendwie waren die halt alle...
...alt und krank und, äh, und jetzt ist, äh, Chico ist ein bisschen jünger, aber ich hoffe, ne, Chico...
...guckt sie zu, als wüsste sie, dass ich über sie rede, äh, also ich hoffe, Chico macht's ein bisschen länger.
So, ähm, jetzt fangen wir mal mit der eigentlichen Geschichte an, was wir machen wollen.
Also, wie gesagt, ich, ich, ich werde, ich versuche mal mit, ähm...
...äh, oh, was hat denn der Raspberry für eine IP gehabt?
So.
Haha!
Tatsächlich.
Ähm...
Also, wie gesagt, außer den Konferenz-Vortrag kenne ich mich damit nicht sonderlich gut aus.
Ich glaub, den Vortrag hier hab ich irgendwie geguckt.
Also, von der Idee her machen wir halt sowas hier.
Wir wollen eine Tabelle haben, wo drin steht, ob meine Raspberries an oder aus sind.
Ähm, und wir wollen ein paar Graphen, also, ne, nachdem ich rausgekriegt hab, ob meine Raspberries an oder aus sind...
...beziehungsweise darauf irgendwelche Services abgekackt sind oder sowas, oder wie, wie voll die Festplatte ist oder sowas...
...will ich, will ich ne Übersicht haben, ähm, haust up, down, und ich will ne Übersicht haben, so nach dem Motto Festplattenplatz, so und so viel frei, so und so viel belegt, und wenn über, sag mal über 90% ist, ähm, dann sollte es halt rot werden oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, muss ich mir mal genau angucken, ähm, da guck ich da einfach abends mal drauf oder lass mir ne Nachricht schicken, dann weiß ich.
Nicht, dass das Ding wieder kaputt ist, weil, wie gesagt, das ist, ähm, der Raspberry im Keller ist vollgelaufen, die SD-Karte.
Und dann ist er abgekackt.
Beziehungsweise man hat's nicht mal weitergemacht.
Und der Raspberry im Keller ist ja eigentlich da, um historische Statistiken für, von der Heizung zu sammeln.
Und dann an meinen Home Assistant, an meine Heimatomatisierung zu schicken.
Und das hat er jetzt nicht gemacht.
Das hab ich auch zu spät gesehen, jetzt hab ich irgendwie so ungefähr ne Woche keine Statistiken und ich hätte jetzt auch nicht festgestellt, wenn die Heizung irgendein Problem hat.
Weil ich mein, das ist, äh, also...
Stromverbrauch, ja? Stromverbrauch leider noch nicht.
Da bin ich grad dabei zu gucken, wie man das...
...am besten macht und das gibt's viele Lösungen und irgendwie gefällt mir davon nix so richtig.
Ja, und...
...daswegen hab ich mir gedacht, es wird jetzt mal an der Zeit, dass ich mitkriege, wenn meine Raspberries abkacken.
Ja, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel der, das TV-Head an der TV-Server abkackt oder so, ist kein Problem.
Da krieg ich mit.
Ja, spätestens wenn einer schreit, dass der Fernseher nicht geht.
Aber ob das Ding jetzt im Keller funktioniert oder nicht, krieg ich nicht mit.
Und das, das probieren wir jetzt mal.
Also, wir müssen übrigens gar nicht auf den Raspberry-Head schauen.
Wir machen uns jetzt erst mal...
Wir machen uns jetzt erst mal einen neuen Container.
Wir machen uns jetzt erst mal einen neuen Rechner oder einen neuen Container zum Testen von Prometheus und von Grafana.
Und dann basteln wir ein bisschen damit rum.
Wie gesagt, ich bin da kein Profi, was das angeht.
Ich hab damit wenig gemacht.
Äh, LXC-Launch...
Oh, wie ging das nochmal? Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken.
Launch...
Ich guck mal nach.
Ich kann mir das...
So, so, genau.
So, allerdings nicht, äh, nennen wir das Neueste.
Kommen wir dem 1810.
Wobei, müsste, müsste nicht jetzt demnächst das neue Ubuntu rauskommen?
Also, müsste doch jetzt eigentlich soweit sein.
Beta von Ubuntu veröffentlicht, ja.
Wann ist denn...
Das kommt wahrscheinlich Ende April oder so, müsste es...
Disco Ding...
Ach du Scheiße.
Disco Dingo, ey.
Oh Gott.
Ja, das wird auch langsam immer...
Naja, ähm...
Am 18. April, okay.
Okay, so geht das.
Also, wir haben 1810 und nennen das Ganze jetzt mal Container, ähm...
Monitor.
Warum gab es nie ein 15.10?
Gab's das nicht?
Also, von der Logik her müsste es das doch eigentlich geben, oder?
Wieso? Gibt's doch.
Oder hab ich...
Ich glaube, ich hab den Gag nicht verstanden.
Beta ist auf Production-Servern.
So, ähm...
Okay, ähm...
Jetzt kommen wir mal...
Lists.
Äh, äh...